hi guys i'm abby Sharpe and welcome to
Abby's kitchen we are back today with
the Ridiculist and for my long-term
followers you know it has been a while
but this one is worth the wait because
we've got a special Kovan 19 Edition now
it's no question that we have all been
bombarded with a stream of coronavirus
related information for the past several
weeks whether it's the growing number of
Statistics worldwide the necessary
safety precautions or the implementation
of new policies to protect the public
while all super valuable it has been a
lot to process so I do hope you're all
hanging in there and staying safe
through these uncertain times but of
course along with this valid information
comes a lot of misinformation and
predatory marketing that you know this
girl will not have obviously one of the
major culprits of this misinformation
have come from wellness influencers and
companies trying to sell or promote
immunity boosting products that claim to
specifically protect against or treat
Cobin 19 insert I roll here now before
we even get into it I want to start by
strongly emphasizing that there is no
one miracle food tincture tea or
over-the-counter product on the market
right now that can prevent against or
treat infection from Cova 19 yes
ensuring we're getting enough sleep
minimizing stress and eating a diet rich
in antioxidant rich fruits and
vegetables can generally support a
healthy immune system but they don't
undo bad hygiene and even healthy people
with healthy immune systems are getting
sick this is a highly contagious virus
so until we have a regulated vaccine
available to the public the only thing
that can protect you for infection are
the recommendations that have been
outlined by health authorities worldwide
so those include number one good hand
hygiene which means washing your hands
for 20 seconds with soap and water
especially after touching surfaces or
being in public
number 2 avoiding touching your face
mouth eyes and nose 3 coughing or
sneezing into your elbow and 4
most importantly practicing social
distancing which means staying home as
much as possible prevent possible
infection and further spread of the
virus and no this does not mean popping
in to your friend's house for a little
coffee date or a wine night and it
certainly doesn't mean meeting up with
your family for dinner or a cute little
movie night social distancing means Park
in your butt and staying the F home now
before we get into it my general
disclaimer that the information in this
video is for education and entertainment
purposes only and you should always seek
the help of a medical professional for
any Co vyd 19 treatment okay whoo let's
do this
glad I wore my sassy pants today so
first up on the ridiculous
the corona virus protocol by herbal Amy
talk about taking advantage of
vulnerable people in desperate times
this protocol claims to prevent and
treat infection through a combination of
a number of different tinctures teas and
oils including a corona virus bond a
settee coronavirus cell protection
coronavirus core tincture corona virus
immune system and an elderberry tincture
whoo that was a mouthful now all of
these products are being sold for the
hefty price of a hundred and fifty-five
dollars yes a hundred and fifty five USD
now the website claims that the herbs
possess powerful antiviral properties to
kill corona viruses it also claims that
the formulas are preventative as well as
specific for acute infections from the
corona virus really Amy really now the
active ingredients in these products
which include elderberry skullcap and
Japanese knotweed have been used in
natural medicine for centuries for their
antiviral properties and while there is
some research to suggest that elderberry
may help treat the flu and skullcap and
Japanese knotweed may have
anti-inflammatory properties they have
not been tested or proven to do anything
with this deadly virus in fact some
experts worry that because of
elderberries immune activating property
it might actually make the illness if
contracted more aggressive again we
don't really know but more
problematically however is that these
products particularly the skullcap and
the not weed may have adverse side
effects including liver damage skullcap
may also cause lung complications
irregular heartbeat and mental confusion
in some people so be sure to speak to
your doctor before taking any of these
kinds of products the shadiest part of
this protocol is the fact that the hand
sanitizer doesn't even contain any
alcohol which is probably because
alcohol is seen as a toxin in a lot of
wellness communities but here's a little
insider tip we kind of need toxins to
kill viruses and hand sanitizer it needs
to be at least 60 percent ethanol or 70
percent isopropyl to even be effective
I'm kind of shocked and honestly a
little offended that enough people spend
a hundred fifty five dollars on this
thing to have to have this protocol sell
out but hey it's your money it's your
life next okay next up on the ridiculous
is bonacic tea by vivify holistic clinic
so this holistic clinic in Sarnia Canada
promoted the use of vana set tea for the
treatment of coronavirus infection
citing alleged findings by Stephen
Bunner an author and herbalist now
Bunner claims to have done extensive
research on corona viruses and has
supposedly treated them successfully
with bonus at tea but this research is
not something I would even call research
he mostly just cites his own books on
herbalist and while providing no real
literature to back up his
sensationalized claims so before it was
taken down the website recommended
drinking this specialty six times daily
to treat an active infection t4 corona
virus this grossly problematic
suggestion has since been removed and
replaced with a note that there are no
claims being made to cure any medical
condition and a seek treatment from your
dr. a plus on the disclaimer but would
have been great to see that in the first
place before they got called out by the
FDA as for the tea itself bonus 'it has
been traditionally used as an herbal
remedy to treat things like influenza
the common cold joint pain fever
pneumonia and other conditions and there
is even some early research to suggest
that taking bonus entity may reduce
symptoms of the common cold but this was
a study done with 53 people and it was
on the cold and it has become very clear
that covin 19 is no cold ingesting bonus
at tea may also come with some risks
including severe diarrhea and vomiting
it also contains chemicals called
pyrolyze 18 alkaloids which have been
known to cause liver damage I don't see
a disclaimer about that on the site mr.
butter thankfully the FDA recently
classified upon a settee as an herb of
unidentified safety because we really
don't know if it's even safe to use
period never mind as a remedy for a
deadly virus the last thing we need to
be dealing with right now is the
potential risks that come with drinking
excessive amounts of diarrhea tea so
save your money stay properly hydrated
and follow the advice of medical
professionals next okay moving on to
colloidal silver now I have seen a lot
of companies peddling the use of
colloidal silver for the treatment of
corona virus this includes the jim
bakker show vital silver jrb enterprise
group and the company called Zephyr
energetics now the jim bakker show aired
a segment promoting the sale of
colloidal silver for a hundred and
twenty five dollars a bottle now on the
show naturopathic doctor cheryl Selman
claimed that even though colloidal
silver hasn't been tested ANCOVA 19 it
has been used with other corona viruses
and has been able to eliminate it within
12 hours I'd like to see your reference
for that similarly one company vital
silver recommends taking two
spoons of colloidal silver twice daily
to kill the virus as they state the
silver will attach to the virus
rendering gum ineffective and boosting
your immune system that is quite the
claim if colloidal silver were really
the saving grace of the corona virus
then I'm pretty sure we wouldn't all be
living in a global pandemic right now
with valuable health care workers
getting violently ill to give you a
brief background on what colloidal
silver even is it's basically a mineral
often used as a homeopathic remedy to
treat bacterial viral and fungal
infections the exact mechanism behind
this is not fully understood mostly
because there's no research to support
these claims but proponents of colloidal
silver claim that it can bind to
bacterial or viral cells and damage
their cell walls and DNA resulting in
cell death not surprisingly the evidence
on this is seriously lacking in fact
colloidal silver has no known function
in the body at all and is not even
considered an essential mineral to begin
with there's also been concerns raised
by the safety and risks of ingesting
colloidal silver as exposure can lead to
the development of something called
argyria which is a condition that turns
the skin of blue gray color as a result
of the buildup of silver particles in
the skin and other organs like the liver
kidneys and intestines so not only as
colloidal silver ineffective at treating
any bacterial or viral infection
including Cova 19 but it may also make
you turn blue I don't think any of us
are trying to turn into the blueberry
girl from Willy Wonka colloidal silver I
am taking a hard pass next all right
next up on the chopping block is none
other than the power of essential oils
now I am all for a nice smelling home
but at this point a house that reeks of
bleach is probably better protected from
coronavirus than one that smells of
diffused lavender and sage using
essential oils to treat and prevent
coronavirus has been recently promoted
by companies like her Ananda and
quintessence aromatherapy
fernanda specifically was promoting the
sale of tea tree and eucalyptus oils as
a means to target Cova 19 on their
website they stated that essential oils
have great potential in the field of
biomedicine
as they effectively destroy bacterial
fungal and viral pathogens by using
these essential oils the company
promises to decrease the chances of
becoming infected with corona virus and
even offers a 50% discount on essential
oil products by using the promo code
Corona really I am generally annoyed
with oil tedlar suggesting that you'll
lose 10 pounds after sniffing ginger but
this is next-level bad now Quin essence
aromatherapy on the other hand claims
that a wide range of essential oils have
been clinically proven to possess
antiviral properties and have measurable
effects on infections including
influenza on their website they have
also stated that since this new strain
of virus continues to be a very serious
threat right now it certainly can't hurt
to use essential oils that you already
have to avoid affection until a cure has
been developed uh I agree I mean it
certainly can't hurt but don't tell
people that it's going to help them
avoid infection ballsy huh what we do
know about essential oils is that they
have long been used in aromatherapy as a
form of alternative medicine to support
general health and well-being there are
over 90 commonly used essential oils
each with their own Associated health
claims with variable levels of efficacy
well I personally love the smell of
lavender oil in my bath before bed and I
have no problem with people using them
therapeutically if it brings them joy I
would never rely on any oil to combat
this serious novel virus and I would
hope that any reputable oil company or
representative wouldn't recommend people
do that so friends if you want to cover
up the smell of disinfectant wipes
lingering on your countertops and door
doorknobs
sure I mean bust out a little diffuser
and get a little citrus scent up in
there
but do not use these as a replacement
for hygiene social distancing and common
sense next
okay moving on to salt therapy by hallow
sense so salt therapy company hello
sense began promoting salt therapy as a
means to protect against Koba 19
claiming that breathing in miniscule
salt particles clears the lungs of
anything that shouldn't be in there
that sounds really specific anyway the
salt particles are allegedly antiviral
and with right preventive measures
through salt therapy they claim that
there is a slim chance you will catch
the disease oh yeah that must be legit
now this is not actually a new wellness
theory breathing in salty air also known
as hallow therapy dates back to the
medieval era proponents of salt therapy
claim that salt cleanses the respiratory
system and can help to treat respiratory
conditions like asthma bronchitis and
allergies however studies on hello
therapy are highly mixed and
inconclusive according to a 2014 review
most studies on how therapy for the
treatment of COPD specifically are
wildly flawed and respiratory experts
are highly skeptical of this technique
as it's not been rigorously studied
enough to recommend also mind you we're
not in a situation where we should all
be running to the spa or a Wellness
Center to receive salt therapy in fact
all of these places have been shut down
thank goodness
along with other non-essential services
luckily the products that we've
mentioned thus far have been flagged by
the FDA as misleading to the public and
were ordered to take immediate action to
correct these violations the FDA is
continuously monitoring and warning
companies who sell these types of
fraudulent products that claim to
prevent diagnose treat or cure Co by 19
Twitter and Facebook have also begun
cracking down on their platforms for
misinformation including the promotion
of Cova 19 related immunity boosting
products if you're interested in a list
of warning letters issued by the FDA I
will leave a link in the description
below if you want to stay up to date and
informed on these types of really
problematic products but until then I
would say just save your money and
breathe normal air at home
next next is simply inulin
now moving on to sketchy influencer
territory let's talk about French
Wellness influencer Ingrid de la Marck
ne now Ingrid promoted the product
simply inulin on her Instagram page as
powerful protection against Koba 19 and
a now-deleted post she claims that a
health professional in Monaco supposedly
recommended the use of the product
simply in Ulan as a means to support the
immune system and make it bulletproof
against the novel coronavirus more than
just a random fan Ingrid just so happens
to sell the product on her online store
uh that is not suspicious at all now for
those of you unfamiliar with inulin it's
a type of prebiotic fiber which helps to
feed the beneficial bacteria in your gut
in doing so it encourages the growth of
healthy gut bacteria like
Bifidobacterium and lactobacilli which
in turn promotes healthy digestion there
are also several known health benefits
of inulin fiber that go beyond to
digestive health some studies have shown
that it may improve blood sugar control
helped relieve constipation and has been
used as a weight loss aid by helping to
keep you fuller longer
one thing that inulin is certainly not
effective towards is making the immune
system bulletproof towards kovat 19 its
fiber folks like not a coveted n95 mask
now though the research showing a link
between a healthy gut and immunity is
well documented these findings pertain
to general immunity and not immunity
towards infection from Cova 19
specifically with the research ANCOVA 19
still in its early stages the role of
general immunity and the gut microbiome
in potentially combating the virus is
just not fully understood it certainly
doesn't hurt to up your intake of inulin
fiber to support a healthy gut in
general immunity but to make a
definitive statement that a particular
product will protect you against corona
virus is just so grossly wrong if you're
interested in improving your gut health
to support general immunity you can do
so by adding more probiotic rich foods
to your diet like yogurt Kim
Mesa or sauerkraut you can also
incorporate more prebiotic fibers into
your meals so foods like asparagus
garlic bananas onions or chicory root
and doing all of that of course while
aiming towards eating more plant-based
foods that are rich in fiber and
antioxidants you don't need a $30
supplement to do that next and finally
let's talk about vitamin mega dosing now
you may or may not have heard about
members of the wellness community such
as Peter Osborne and Andrew Saul
recommending mega doses of antioxidants
like vitamin A C and D as a means to
protect against Koba 19 not only are
these recommendations not supported by
the evidence but they may actually be
extremely dangerous these people are
recommending doses that are way beyond
the recommended amounts for each vitamin
and they pose some serious health risks
vitamin C for example does have a role
in immunity and wound healing and can be
obtained from the diet by eating a
variety of fruits and vegetables because
vitamin C is water-soluble it does not
get stored in the body and any excess is
extruded out in your piece however this
is mostly true for food sources of
vitamin C whereas supplemental forms of
vitamin C are not excreted as easily
from the body leading to an increased
risk of toxicity 1 2019 review did find
that oral and IV high doses of vitamin C
treatment may reduce ICU stay by 8% and
shortened ventillation duration by 18.2%
however in practice including early
experiments with Coppa 19 patients
doctors would never give these high
amounts orally they would need to be
administered through an IV very
carefully monitored by a doctor
the reason is that excess vitamin C
supplementation is not necessarily
benign access vitamin C supplementation
can cause adverse health effects ranging
from digestive symptoms like diarrhea
and nausea to the development of kidney
stones and it may also lead to iron
overload which can be seriously damaging
for organs like the heart liver and
pancreas
these adverse effects appear to occur
when people are taking vitamin C doses
just over 2,000 milligrams and our
friends Peter Osborne and Andrew soul
are recommending between 5,000 and
24,000 milligrams
folks you may not need to go to the ER
for kovat but you'll be praying they
have a bed when your liver fails as for
vitamin D low levels of vitamin D have
been associated with respiratory disease
as well as viral respiratory infections
and decreased lung function well we
don't have actual research on vitamin D
for kovat it does make sense that we
would want to keep our vitamin levels in
check especially considering the high
prevalence of vitamin D deficiency
worldwide but as for high single doses a
systematic review concluded that single
doses of vitamin D up to a hundred
thousand is may be effective at
improving vitamin D status to prevent
deficiency while under medical
supervision
my view these are findings not
recommendations and they pertain to a
single dose every three months not daily
dosages also similar to vitamin C
vitamin D also has potential risks from
high school mental doses including
elevated calcium levels digestive
symptoms dizziness confusion nausea
vomiting stomach pain bone loss and even
kidney failure toxicity is also more
likely to occur in people taking high
dose up laments as it is very unlikely
to reach high blood levels through diet
alone contrary to vitamin C vitamin D is
fat soluble meaning it's stored in the
body fat and released into the
bloodstream slowly versus being excreted
immediately in the urine because we're
able to have vitamin D stores this means
that the effects of vitamin D toxicity
may potentially last for several months
after you stop taking the supplements so
the recommended daily amounts for adults
is just 600 I use compared to Peter
Osborne's recommendation of a hundred
and fifty thousand I use of vitamin D I
am pretty good at taking a lot of
supplements at once but I would have to
take 250 vitamin D tablets per day just
to reach those recommendations
that would work out to around three
hundred dollars per week nope
as for the risks of high supplemental
doses of vitamin A they may include
vision changes bone pain skin changes
respiratory infection and possible
kidney and liver damage Peter Osborne
recommends 75 micrograms of vitamin A
which is more than eight times the
recommended daily amount of 700 to 900
micrograms for adults so yeah just
please don't bottom line there is
absolutely nothing safe about taking
mega doses of vitamin supplements
without medical supervision as these can
cause some serious adverse health risks
which may even land you in the hospital
and that is probably the last place you
want to be during a global pandemic so
please save your money get your vitamins
mainly from food sources take your usual
vitamin doses and talk to a doctor or
dietitian before starting any new
supplements now I want to just conclude
with some general immunity tips so the
big question coronavirus or no
coronavirus is there anything that we
can do naturally to support our immune
system for general health and well-being
according to the research the answer is
yes there is though no one food or
supplement can prevent illness or
infection you can always support your
immune system through a balanced diet
that includes adequate sources of
protein like lean meat poultry fish eggs
tofu beans legumes vitamin A from
sources like orange or yellow vegetables
and fruits and dark leafy greens vitamin
C from things like citrus fruits and a
wide variety of vegetables vitamin E
from healthy fat sources like nuts and
oils and zinc from whole grains beans
nuts and animal protein in addition to
supporting the immune system through
food you can also support a healthy
immune system through lifestyle changes
by getting adequate sleep exercising
regularly and managing stress bottom
line though immunity boosting sure is a
buzzword these days
the reality is there
is currently no known cures or
preventative treatments for Cova 19
though research is still underway to
develop a vaccine no food or product on
the market can promise immunity or
protection from this virus so be
skeptical of anyone trying to sell or
promote a product that makes these
extreme and sensationalized promises
also be skeptical of anyone who
simultaneously tries to sell these
themselves without giving alternative
product suggestions again I want to
emphasize that while taking care of your
general health should always be a
priority not just in a pandemic the most
important things that you can
immediately do to protect yourself and
others is to wash your hands avoid
touching your face and practice social
distancing well folks that is all for
this episode of the ridiculous please
continue to stay safe and stay critical
of misinformation online of course leave
me a comment below like this video
subscribe and I will see you next time
on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]